[MUSIC PLAYING]
JENNA TAYLOR: So today, we
are super excited to have
Jami Curl of Portland's QUIN.
JAMI CURL: Yes.
JENNA TAYLOR: Candy is magic.
And I think we've got the
modern-day Willy Wonka with us
today.
So join me in welcoming
her to Google.
JAMI CURL: Thank you.
JENNA TAYLOR: Thanks
for being here.
JAMI CURL: Thank
you for having me.
I'm happy to be here.
JENNA TAYLOR: So what
are you going to do?
JAMI CURL: Well,
I would like first
to just tell you a little bit.
I'm sure you like have gathered
what we're doing here, which
is that at QUIN, and sort
of in my life philosophy,
we make candy with real food.
That's like the bottom line.
So you have mass-produced
candy, which has chemically made
stuff taste like real food.
But what we do with
candy is use real food
to make candy that tastes like
real, real food, essentially.
JENNA TAYLOR: And real
quality ingredients are core
to Google's food philosophy--
JAMI CURL: That's what I heard.
JENNA TAYLOR: --which is
part of the reason we wanted
to partner with Jami, right?
We believe in like an 80/20
balance, healthy and indulgent
in life.
So there's a place for candy.
But we really believe it
should be the highest quality
ingredients, cared for
in the best possible way,
and you'll get the most
delicious end product which I'm
pretty sure we're prove today.
JAMI CURL: I hope so, yes.
So throughout the
book, which is in front
of some of you, which
is this book that we
have called "Candy is Magic"--
JENNA TAYLOR: And available
for sale in the back--
JAMI CURL: --available
for sale in the back.
And we use-- so what
we're going to do
is go through these
different recipes that
use the strawberry.
You guys live in a great
place for strawberries.
JENNA TAYLOR: And it's about to
be strawberry time around here.
So perfect.
JAMI CURL: Yeah.
And that said, the recipes
we're going to do today,
if you wanted to do this when
it wasn't strawberry time--
like in Oregon, strawberry
season is like two days long--
so for most of the year,
we get frozen strawberries
from farms that,
during harvest season,
harvest all the
strawberries, and then
freeze them for people
like me who then go and buy
big buckets of frozen
berries essentially.
So the nice thing about it
is that any of the fruit
stuff that's in here, if you can
buy it frozen, you can use it.
It totally goes right into
the recipes in the same way
that it does.
JENNA TAYLOR: Good to know.
JAMI CURL: Yeah.
The way that we do it, though,
to use real fruit to turn it
into candy is that all the
fruit has to be roasted first
to remove some of the
moisture that's in the fruit
so that you can kind of
control the outcome of candy
a little bit better.
So that's where
we're going to start,
which is essentially this
sort of roasted strawberry
with lemon.
So we have here
some strawberries.
This recipe is in the book.
Oh, look, you're
following along.
Good googler.
AUDIENCE: Page 37.
JAMI CURL: Yes, it is
page 37 in the book.
And essentially, this is super
easy, because all you're doing
is taking fruit, putting it on
a pan, adding some stuff to it,
throwing it in the
oven, and allowing it
to roast until it gets to--
this is perfectly done.
This pan here is
a great example.
It has some really
darkened edges on it.
So you can tell the
strawberries have shrunk down.
Obviously, what's left
there is a lot of very
intense strawberry
flavor, because you take
the strawberries
whole, fine, even
the big ones, like this giant
guy, you can leave it big.
And then you put a
little lemon juice on it.
And the lemon juice brightens
the flavor of the strawberries.
And then you're going to
add sugar to it, as well,
and a little bit
of vanilla bean.
Just a little.
JENNA TAYLOR: Is this
the kind of thing
you could do in advance
and then keep it
if you didn't have time
to do the whole recipe?
JAMI CURL: Say you are
growing your own strawberries,
and you have the
strawberriest thumb of anyone
you know, and you have--
your 2017 harvest of
strawberries is very--
your yield is huge, you can
make this puree ahead and then
freeze it, and
then, you can make
with it, ice cream,
strawberry marshmallows,
strawberry lollipops,
like a bazillion things.
So just keep it around
in your freezer.
The other thing you can
do, which we'll talk about
is you can keep it
in your freezer--
or your fridge for
a couple of weeks,
but your freezer kind of
indefinitely-- and let it thaw.
Then you can mix it into
yogurt, or your cottage cheese,
or anything that you
like berries mixed into.
JENNA TAYLOR: So this is
going to become a kitchen
all-star for everyone.
JAMI CURL: Yes.
JENNA TAYLOR: Love it.
JAMI CURL: OK, so then you
put a little bit of sugar
on those berries.
And then there's a little bit of
vanilla bean that goes into it.
And you would put that on there.
And then this is a
little kitchen magic
because you would put
this into your oven that's
been pre-heated.
Are you ready for it?
Wait for it.
And then magically, ta-da!
You have this.
[APPLAUSE]
Right, yes.
It is magic.
It's definitely magic.
So then once you
have these berries,
you puree them in a blender.
JENNA TAYLOR: Do you want
all this good stuff in there?
Or do you try to keep the
more caramelized parts out?
JAMI CURL: I'll tell you that
in the recipe in the book, when
you do puree it, you
basically put the berries in.
And it depends upon the fruit.
Not every fruit is the same
way, because some of it,
you would strain out a
little bit of the juice,
because it's going to
be too juicy to have
the candy turn out correctly.
But these look good
enough to where
you would just put everything
that's on here in the blender,
yes.
OK, so that step is pretty easy.
So I would like you all to
engage your imagination.
I have put these berries
into the blender,
and I have turned it on.
And I have let the blender
run for one full minute.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's an
extremely quiet blender.
It's a new technology.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMI CURL: Do you hear it?
And then it turns into this.
It's like a velvety,
delicious strawberry puree.
Can everyone see it?
OK, good.
So then we'll save the
noise of the blender.
So what we've got is we've put
the ingredients on the tray.
We've roasted the berries.
They turn out like that.
It's beautiful.
You put it in here,
and you blend it.
And then voila, beautiful.
So the first thing
that you can do
is make ice cream
if you wanted to.
And I think everybody
likes ice cream.
So in the book, there's a sort
of base recipe for vanilla bean
ice cream.
And you can then--
if you're really following
along, this is on page 100.
But you basically use this
easy vanilla ice cream base
to make a lot of
other ice creams,
including strawberry ice cream.
And it's super easy,
because all you're doing
is making a cream that
has vanilla bean in it,
like mixing cream and
vanilla bean together,
sort of like these.
And then you heat this
cream up in a pan,
which we'll do over here.
It looks like a lot
of vanilla bean.
And I'll tell you that I like
a lot of vanilla in everything
that I make--
cookies, cakes, everything.
And I make like
pretty normal cookies.
I used to own a
bakery, actually.
And I baked for like nine
years as the owner of a bakery.
And people were like,
the cookies are the best.
You make the best
cookies in the world.
And the real secret--
oh, thank you--
is that it just has a
lot of vanilla in it.
So if you want to make like,
real world-class bakery
cookies, just add more vanilla
than the recipe calls for.
And people will be like, this
is the most amazing thing
I have ever had.
And it's like, well thank you.
JENNA TAYLOR: Secret ingredient.
JAMI CURL: So
you've got this on.
JENNA TAYLOR: I'm glad
you know how to do that.
JAMI CURL: They
gave me a lesson.
JENNA TAYLOR: I
still don't ever.
JAMI CURL: I was given a lesson.
JENNA TAYLOR: I've
done this 100 times.
JAMI CURL: OK, so
that actually leads me
to this really good thing.
So you're all like,
you know, what I
don't have is a candy factory.
So cool, we have this book now.
But how are we going to have the
fancy stuff to make the candy?
We don't use anything fancy
to make the candy at all.
We use induction cooktops
and six human beings.
And we make $20,000
lollipops in four days,
like one person can
do that, because how
we run production is
we don't let anyone,
A, have a choice over what candy
they make, which is terrible.
It's not that good for morale.
JENNA TAYLOR: But
it's all candy.
JAMI CURL: It is all candy.
And it's a very--
JENNA TAYLOR: Is
there candy drudgery?
JAMI CURL: A little.
It's a very sweet
environment, yes.
But it is really a great
idea production-wise--
and I'm sure all of you in
this room understand process
and the importance of it--
we establish a real expert
in one area of candy-making.
So one person makes lollipops.
And because that person does it
over, and over, and over again,
then they turn into
this like human machine,
which is what I'm aiming for.
So it's better than it sounds.
JENNA TAYLOR: Lollipop machine.
JAMI CURL: Yes, yes.
So that person can then
become so skilled at it
that when we get a giant order
for lollipops, we don't panic.
Instead, it's like yes.
We can handle this.
We will make your 35,000
lollipops in two weeks
with one person doing
it, which is amazing.
But we can do it.
And it's because
of this repetition.
So anyways, back to the, you
don't need a lot of equipment.
So to make the candy, all the
recipes in the book, the most--
the trickiest thing
that is nice to have
is a thermometer, because
that helps with hard candy,
gumdrops, and marshmallows.
But the rest of
it, as you can see,
it's just like stuff you
have around your kitchen.
We're going to
look at this later.
But this is a candy funnel.
But you can use a glass
measuring cup instead of this.
And I'll show you when we
get to the lollipop part.
So it's not this huge
investment in a ton of equipment
that you only use
for candy-making.
It's like you have a
pot, you have some bowls,
you have a blender.
Maybe you have an
ice cream maker.
And then you don't really
need many other things.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the recipe you're making.
JAMI CURL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So there's a
lot of vanilla bean--
you have a lot of seed in there.
JAMI CURL: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Using
paste, vanilla paste?
JAMI CURL: We use vanilla
beans that have just
been put into a coffee
grinder and have been
pulverized, the whole bean.
So the pod and the seeds inside.
AUDIENCE: Great.
JAMI CURL: But you can
also scrape a vanilla bean
and put it in-- however
you choose to do it.
AUDIENCE: So much more
flavor in the skin though.
JAMI CURL: Yeah.
Yes.
Exactly, yes.
OK, all right.
So basically, to make the
vanilla ice cream base,
you get this cream heated up.
And then you add sugar.
And one really great--
JENNA TAYLOR: It does smell like
the most delicious ice cream
base in the world.
JAMI CURL: It is.
The thing about it--
I'm sure that several
of you in here
have made ice cream before.
And this isn't the type of
ice cream that you have eggs,
and you're doing tempering,
and you're adding things to--
this is honestly just cream, and
fruit, and vanilla, and sugar.
So it is totally
delicious because there's
so much fat in it.
I was just saying on the--
JENNA TAYLOR:
High-quality fat is OK.
JAMI CURL: I was just saying
on the way here in the car,
that when you make the chocolate
ice cream that's in the book,
it doesn't even
melt. You can let
it sit out for like two hours.
And it's still the
shape of the scoop other
than it's like room
temperature ice cream,
when it's like a whole other
experience of ice cream
totally.
AUDIENCE: So you
really are Willy Wonka.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah.
She's totally Willy Wonka.
She makes non-melting ice cream.
JAMI CURL: Thank you.
Thank you.
JENNA TAYLOR: And
the secret is fat.
JAMI CURL: Yeah, well, yes.
Isn't it to everything?
I swear.
But I--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JAMI CURL: Yes.
Yes.
It is and it's
the texture of it,
when you eat it right away
is like, totally delicious,
smooth, so creamy, and lovely.
But like a month from now, if
you keep it in your freezer,
it won't have that same
feeling, because there's
nothing in it to extend the
life of it, no like xanthan
gum and all that
crummy stuff to keep
it to have the same mouthfeel.
So when you do make this ice
cream, make it in the morning,
put it in the freezer
so it hardens,
and then serve it for
dinner that night.
And none of the recipes
have a huge field,
so you don't have to
worry about having this--
I mean, there's no such
thing as too much ice cream,
I don't think.
So pretty easy that way.
JENNA TAYLOR: Plus one.
Totally agree.
JAMI CURL: All right,
so once this is heated,
you add your sugar in.
And this is like one of the tips
that I can give you on this.
You're looking for the sugar
to melt. And one of the ways
to see that it's melted is if
you sort of pull the pan aside,
and then let some of the
cream drip off your spoon,
then you can see if
it's dissolved or not.
So you're just looking for
the sugar to become dissolved.
And once it has dissolved, then
got this easy vanilla bean ice
cream base, which is what you
need to make strawberry ice
cream with.
So if you're following along--
some of you are--
the strawberry ice
cream is page 102.
So this is super easy
because then all you
need is this vanilla ice cream
base and some strawberry puree.
And then you turn it into ice
cream, which is also awesome.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] powder?
JAMI CURL: Yes.
vanilla bean powder is
a great way to do it.
And you make your own by
just putting a vanilla bean
in a coffee grinder.
And even if you leave
the vanilla bean
out on your countertop
for a couple of days
so it dries a little bit,
if you have an especially
sort of sticky one,
then you just put it, in
and it grinds it up.
But you can also buy
vanilla bean powder.
Now listen, when
I wrote the book,
vanilla bean powder
was around $50 a pound.
You're not going to
buy a pound of it.
You're going by a tiny bit.
But then last week,
we got an email
from our person who we get
our vanilla bean powder from,
and vanilla bean powder has
gone up to $285 a pound.
So I--
JENNA TAYLOR: Don't buy it.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMI CURL: I didn't write
the book with the knowledge
that it was that expensive.
JENNA TAYLOR:
Gold-plated vanilla bean.
JAMI CURL: So when
you get to that part
and then you go look it up
online, and you're like,
this lady is insane, I'm
not actually that crazy.
But it has become a--
it's a slight deterrent.
JENNA TAYLOR: Vanilla
struggle is real these days.
It's really intense.
JAMI CURL: Yes, yes.
OK, so doesn't that smell nice?
And it's nice and hot.
JENNA TAYLOR: It smells amazing.
JAMI CURL: So you've got
this vanilla bean cream
base that way.
And you will chill it.
And once it's
chilled, you magically
have this, which is that
that has been cooled down.
It's a little bit brown in
color because the vanilla
has seeped all through it.
And what you would do at that
point is you've got over here,
honestly, you just
take this base--
who wants to come
with me to do this?
You can come.
And you add the
strawberry to it.
Then you would mix
it all up, possibly
a whisk could be a
better job for that,
a better tool for the job.
AUDIENCE: Is that
just a single batch
of the roasted strawberries?
Is that about what
it would yield?
Any? how many?
JAMI CURL: This is
sort of a sampling.
But the bowl that
I had before, yeah.
It's like between
a pint and a quart
of the roasted
strawberries, depending
upon how much moisture you get
out of it, how big your berries
were, that kind of thing.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Did you
strain the strawberries
after you pureed it all?
JAMI CURL: Fruit-wise, it
depends upon the fruit,
because some strawberries
are super juicy,
blackberries are a
super juicy fruit.
Peaches are not as juicy.
So if there's a ton--
in the recipes of the
book, it indicates,
like this would be a good
time to strain some of it
out so that it's a
little bit more--
so you can control the
outcome of your candy.
But some strawberries--
like this,
I wouldn't have strained the
strawberries that we have here,
just because they're--
you can sort of see there's
not a ton of liquid left.
OK, all right.
So now that you've got the
strawberries and the vanilla
together, this is chilled.
That's one important thing.
And then you have your ice
cream machine attachment,
or fancy countertop
ice cream compressor
machine, which,
if you have that,
I'll come over after this is
done and We'll make ice cream.
Or when you get done with work.
Whenever.
And then you're going
to add it in there
to your ice cream-maker.
Let it's spin.
And basically, you're
just going to let
this go until it turns into
ice cream, which is never
a bad thing.
And then, yes, from that
point, after this spins,
put it in your freezer.
Let it harden up so that
it's sort of scoopable.
And then I would say, eat it
within the week or the day
that you make it,
because you can't wait,
because you know
it's so delicious.
OK.
So do we want to eat ice cream?
We're going to wait to
the end to eat ice cream?
OK.
You can't have it yet, you guys.
JENNA TAYLOR: You can have it.
You just have to wait.
JAMI CURL: One of the things--
that's actually a really good--
JENNA TAYLOR: You
have candy already.
Eat your candy.
JAMI CURL: You do have candy.
One of the things that I
love about candy the most
and making all the things
that come from candy
is that it does teach
a lot about process.
And it does teach you a lot
about patience, for sure.
We're going to be
patient for ice cream.
That's what I'm saying this.
All the recipes that
we make at QUIN,
and all the candy
that you're enjoying,
and everything in the
book, I made all of it up.
And I didn't come like from the
candy company down the street
and get a new job, or like
make my own candy company up,
because they wanted
to change the way--
I made it all up.
I had a bakery for nine years.
And that was a good time.
It was fun.
It was a lot of work, because
it was like a retail bakery.
So every day, we had fresh
product, nothing day-old.
Just a ton of work to do it.
And I had 30 employees
in a couple of locations.
And it was real
dedicated situation.
And I started making
candy because I
was bored with cookies, and
cakes, and muffins, and scones,
and morning stuff.
So I made a batch of caramel.
And it worked.
And that was the thing--
I was like, OK, this is great.
Like, you can cut it, and put
it in a wrapper, and sell it.
So we sold it at the
counters of the bakery.
And then the next
candy that I made
was a lollipop, which
we're going to make next.
And the idea of taking
something that is a liquid
and transforming it into
something that holds up
on a stick, I was like,
I'm a wizard, because I
used real fruit in it.
And that's sort of
how the philosophy
behind the way
that we made candy
came into play, because
I did it all in a bakery.
And there are strawberries.
And here is like a refrigerator
full of fresh dairy products.
And so it was easy
to come up with candy
that used the stuff that was
around me, A, I'm pretty cheap.
And I don't like to
spend a lot of money
if I don't know something
is going to work.
So I don't invest in a lot
of equipment or anything.
You'll see.
We do it all very, very by hand.
So that is--
JENNA TAYLOR:
Strawberry lollipops.
JAMI CURL: Yes,
strawberry lollipops.
JENNA TAYLOR: Using the
same strawberry puree?
JAMI CURL: Right.
So you have your
roasted strawberry puree
that you have put
in your refrigerator
or in your freezer.
And you made your ice cream.
And now you think,
what else can I make?
And what else you can
make is candy, lollipops.
So the strawberry
lollipop is beautiful,
because we didn't
really strain any
of the seeds out of the puree
so that you can see them when
you hold it up to the light.
You have the blackberry
lollipops now.
So you can kind of get the feel
for what I'm talking about.
So this is pretty
easy for candy making,
because you take sugar,
glucose, and water.
And you add it to the pot.
But I'm going to tell you
a little bit about glucose
before we do that.
So glucose is this thing
called an interfering agent.
And when you melt sugar-- which
you have to do with a little
bit of water so that it
will completely dissolve--
after that has happened,
sugar is always
fighting to turn
back into a crystal.
So basically, what
candy-making really
is, is controlling sugar
from recrystallizing.
That's like the
bottom line of it.
So what glucose does is, say two
little bits of sugar in a pot,
and they've melted.
But one is like, oh I really
liked being a crystal.
And the other one is
like, I liked it, too.
Let's form a gang.
And so they come together,
and then they form a crystal.
And then all the other sugars
are like, that's a great idea.
I want to do it, too.
And then they all recrystallize.
But what the glucose does is it
comes right between those two
renegade bits of
sugar and interferes
in them crystallizing.
So the glucose that
we use is French.
So it's very fancy.
JENNA TAYLOR: Super
fancy glucose.
JAMI CURL: But
the reason that we
use it is because it
comes from Europe.
So it's guaranteed
to be non-GMO.
And it is basically
derived from the potato.
So it's not corn syrup.
It's not also potato
syrup, because by the time
it ends up as glucose,
which is essentially
like an invert sugar,
none of the parts
that made it exist anymore,
because it has been
so transformed into what it is.
Yet, amazingly enough, it's
still a natural product.
So we can use it.
JENNA TAYLOR: And is that
something we just get online?
JAMI CURL: Yeah.
You can buy it online.
You can get it at any
cake-decorating store.
Even like Michael's, the craft
store, in the Wilton aisle
where they have the fondant,
and the little rollers,
and the cutters, and all that,
you can get it there, too.
Do you have Chef's
Warehouse here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JAMI CURL: Anybody know about--
Do you have Chef's Warehouse?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JAMI CURL: Yeah?
Yeah?
So you can do a will-call at
Chef's Warehouse where any
specialty product--
as long as you pay for it ahead
of time and go pick it up--
you can get like any, even
5 gallons of olive oil
if you need to.
But you can get
glucose through a--
Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What
does it taste like?
JENNA TAYLOR: What does
glucose taste like?
JAMI CURL: It doesn't
taste as sweet as sugar.
Do you want to taste it?
[LAUGHTER]
JENNA TAYLOR: You know
you want to taste it.
We have a tasting spoon.
Test them.
JAMI CURL: And then
you can report back.
JENNA TAYLOR: You
tell the group.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JAMI CURL: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: It's like not
sweet pancake syrup.
JAMI CURL: Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: Unsweetened
pancake syrup.
JAMI CURL: It's the consistency
of like a syrup in general.
Yes.
So there you go so.
Sugar and close
together equal sort of
like a medium-sweet thing.
So if you were to eat--
like we have some candy that
we'll compare later--
to make mass
produced candy, they
use high-fructose corn
syrup and sucrose normally
as a combination.
That is sweeter
than actual sugar.
And that's one of the reasons
that mass-produced candy
is so addictive, because
it creates something that
is unnatural in the real
world, because it is actually
sweeter than sugar.
We have some candy
side by side that we
can compare, especially
noticeable with the Starburst
and the strawberry Dreams
Come True side by side.
It's amazing.
To me it's amazing.
I mean, I'm also
like a total nerd.
JENNA TAYLOR:
Let's go with that.
I think "amazing" is
an appropriate word.
JAMI CURL: It is amazing, yes.
So we have in the pot,
sugar, the glucose, which
is not-sweet pancake syrup.
JENNA TAYLOR: Technical term.
JAMI CURL: Mm-hmm, mm-hmm--
and water.
Then we turn it on.
I know you guys
probably all know
how to use your stovetops
at home, how they turn on.
JENNA TAYLOR: Maybe.
Maybe not.
JAMI CURL: Yes?
And so then at this point
what you want to do, is poke.
Don't stir.
And the reason you
poke and not stir
is because any unnecessary
agitation to the pot
could cause the
glucose to sort of lose
its footing in its
interfering process
and could still result in
something that's crystallized.
So you just sort of poke
it in until the sugar
is uniformly wet.
JENNA TAYLOR:
That's fascinating.
I hadn't heard that before.
Poke, don't stir.
JAMI CURL: Poke.
Don't stir.
If I could get a
tattoo of something,
that's what it would be.
JENNA TAYLOR: A
pretty good tattoo.
JAMI CURL: Well, OK.
That's a good one.
JENNA TAYLOR: You'd spend a
lot of explaining that one.
It's really about candy-making.
I swear.
JAMI CURL: See, it is.
It is.
As a 90-year-old--
A good one, too.
That's a-- yeah.
OK so we're poking it.
And we're going to basically
put this over medium-high heat
and just let it come to a boil.
And one of the good
things here is that--
this isn't a part of
the process to rush.
You want to let it be
over medium-high heat
so that it will come to
temp, melt all the sugar,
the glucose can
start doing its job,
all work together like
that so that eventually you
come to a very nice
crystal-clear candy
at the very end.
So let's let this
come up to a boil
What do you want to talk about?
JENNA TAYLOR: Put
me on the spot.
I was watching.
I wasn't coming up with ideas.
No, is there some way
you could mess this up?
JAMI CURL: Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: What
should we not do?
JAMI CURL: OK, the first
thing you should not do
is be afraid of it.
That's the very first thing.
JENNA TAYLOR: Don't be scared.
JAMI CURL: Don't be scared,
because the making candy is not
unlike making like a pot
of soup or some tomato
sauce for your pasta.
All you're doing is putting
ingredients in a pot
and heating it up.
It's easy.
The thing that
scares most people
is like the part where
you get to the point
where you have to
use a thermometer.
So to be honest,
accuracy is really
great in candy-making, which
is why we weigh everything.
Everything is sort
of done by the gram
so that it's very, very
precise, because it
helps with your outcome.
And what I don't want
to do is like write
a book that has like, a little
of this, a little of that.
And then it doesn't turn
out for the home reader.
I don't know about you, but
I read a lot of cookbooks.
JENNA TAYLOR: Super frustrating.
JAMI CURL: And I get very
frustrated when you've
spent the time and
the money, and you
have invested this part
of yourself to do it,
and it doesn't turn out.
So I like to be very precise.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's appreciated
from the consumer side, surely.
JAMI CURL: Well, yes.
But then you get people who
are like, why is it so fluffy?
JENNA TAYLOR:
Because it's candy.
JAMI CURL: Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's like science.
Be precise.
JAMI CURL: Yes so
don't be afraid,
because that will be your first
step in sort of messing it up,
because you're just
defeating yourself
by starting out scared.
JENNA TAYLOR: Olivia has
a question really quick.
JAMI CURL: Yes?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
So last two times I
made caramel or toffee,
I literally burned
myself really badly,
because I just can't remember
that the candy is hot,
because it doesn't
steam or anything.
So how do remember?
JENNA TAYLOR: How do you
remember your candy's hot
so you don't burn yourself?
AUDIENCE: Like on my
arm, it's really bad.
JAMI CURL: Whoa, OK.
JENNA TAYLOR: No, It's funny.
Actually, the first time
I ever made caramel,
it looked so beautiful.
I was like, oh totally
burned my finger.
JAMI CURL: While it
was inside the pot?
JENNA TAYLOR: No, like
after I laid it out.
JAMI CURL: Oh, yeah.
That's really-- I mean it
takes a long time to cool.
So it is very hot.
We should make something--
a sign for you.
JENNA TAYLOR: The answer
is we'll make you a sign.
JAMI CURL: Yes, like hot.
JENNA TAYLOR: Watch out.
It's hot.
JAMI CURL: Hot, hot,
hot pan, hot something,
because that's the thing.
Maybe just get it
sort of into your head
that it actually does
take a long time to cool.
The caramel that we
make, we actually
usually let it cool
overnight before we cut it.
And it's not because
it's hot the whole time,
but it actually just
helps in setting it up
so it's easier to cut.
But we pour it into a--
JENNA TAYLOR: But we're
back to patience now.
JAMI CURL: Yes, we are, which
is one of the best teaching
tools about candy is patience.
Trust the process
and be patient.
OK, is that helpful?
Do you want me to come over?
AUDIENCE: Yes, I do.
I have induction.
JAMI CURL: You do?
I like induction.
JENNA TAYLOR: Do you
induction and an ice
cream-making machine?
Now you're stacking
up the reasons.
JAMI CURL: All right, and then
what else can you mess up?
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah.
What else do not do?
JAMI CURL: Undercooking.
I wouldn't undercook the candy.
We're going to cook this to
a temperature of 315 degrees.
That doesn't mean
like 310 because it
got like close enough to 315.
JENNA TAYLOR: It means 315.
JAMI CURL: Yeah, 315.
But if you go over,
that's going to be OK.
So that's like the
thing, 315 for sure.
But if you stick your
thermometer in the pot,
and you see it's like
319, that doesn't
mean you should throw
away what you're doing.
Just proceed and be confident.
JENNA TAYLOR: But if it
says 310, keep going.
JAMI CURL: Keep going, yes.
JENNA TAYLOR: Be
committed to the temp.
JAMI CURL: Exactly.
Yes.
commit to the 315, exactly.
JENNA TAYLOR: So
don't be afraid.
Don't undercook it.
What else?
Keys to success.
JAMI CURL: Don't undercook it.
And while you're waiting
for your candy to cook,
swirl the pot.
JENNA TAYLOR: So
poke, don't stir.
Swirl.
JAMI CURL: And
after the sugar has
become sort of
uniformly wet and you
have it boiling a little
bit, just swirl the pot.
Swirl it.
JENNA TAYLOR: Gently give the
pot a little wax on, wax off.
JAMI CURL: And that's mostly
to distribute the heat
so that when you go to
take the temperature,
you're taking a
temperature that's
hopefully uniform
throughout the whole pot.
JENNA TAYLOR: So this
is the kind of thing
you should not walk away from.
JAMI CURL: Well, you know,
I was just going to say,
while this is cooking, you
could do this one other thing.
JENNA TAYLOR: As long
as it doesn't boil over.
JAMI CURL: This doesn't mean
like go to the other room
and switch the clothes from
the washer to the dryer.
I don't mean that.
I mean you could go--
JENNA TAYLOR: Stand
right here near it,
so you can still see it.
JAMI CURL: Yeah.
There's two ways to sort
of shape the lollipops
once you have the syrup cooked.
You can use molds.
Or you can use a nonstick mat.
So the nonstick
is how we started
making all of the candy,
all the lollipops at QUIN.
We did not have molds at all.
The mold costs
around like $1.15.
This is how crazy am.
But I would not
buy them, because I
was like, who knows if
these lollipops will work.
Let's just do it on
the nonstick mats.
So you can kind of see this
organic shape in the book.
The cover of the book features
perfectly molded lollipops.
But the lollipops, say, on page
118, are more organic in shape
because those have just
been poured out on a mat.
So while this is coming
to tamp, what you could do
is take your lollipop sticks
and set them out on your mat
so that they're ready to have
the candy poured over them.
Or you could fill your
mold with the sticks
while you're waiting.
AUDIENCE: In a
mat like a Silpat?
JAMI CURL: Yeah, a Silpat.
Yep, exactly.
Super easy.
You can sort of
fill it in there.
And you know what
makes it even easier
is if you grab a piece
of parchment paper
and take something
that's 1 and 1/2 inches
round, because that's
around the size that's
kind of nice for your mouth.
Use a Sharpie and draw
those circles spread out
on the parchment.
Then put the Silpat
over the top of it.
Then place the stick
sort of in the circle.
Then you have like
a guide so that
you don't make like an
unwrappable, giant--
I mean, you can make huge ones.
No problem.
It's just a little
harder to wrap those.
Can you guys hear this?
This is actually
really good advice.
If you're going to pour your
lollipops out on a Silpat,
Jami was saying you can draw
circles on parchment the size
you want, put the
parchment under your Silpat
so you have kind of a guide as
you're pouring out your candy.
Yeah, because you can
see, it through the mat.
And it makes it where
you have a guide--
for size, exactly.
So you could do big, small.
But cellophane, which is
what we wrap the candy in,
like you've seen it, you can
get it in all various sizes.
So just make sure the lollipop
size you're making sort
of matches the cellophane
that you're going to use.
We use like between
4 and 5 inches.
AUDIENCE: Are the lollipops too
sticky to just do it directly
on the parchment paper?
And that's why--
JAMI CURL: Yeah.
Yes, yes, yes.
They're almost too sticky even
just for the regular lollipop
mold.
The funny thing
about a lollipop mold
is the first time-- you
buy a mold like this,
you get it on the internet.
And it's around $1.15.
And you get it you get
your first one in the mail,
and you're like sweet.
And you make your candy, and it
does not come out of the mold
at all.
And you're like, what did I do?
So then you're like, well,
maybe I'll oil the mold.
So you oil the mold.
And then it comes out and
then you clean the mold.
And then every lollipop you make
after that always comes out.
It's like they just need like
they need to be broken-in.
JENNA TAYLOR: They
need to be cured.
JAMI CURL: Yeah, you have
to cure the lollipop mold.
JENNA TAYLOR: Good to know.
JAMI CURL: So these
will all come out.
But we have had a lot
of sticky, sticky stuff.
OK.
So the same thing that
we're doing right now
is used for a lot of
the lollipop recipes
throughout the book.
OK, one other thing--
maybe you can see--
if you get a little sugar that's
stuck to the side of your pot
and you want to just
poke it down in, you can.
You could use a pastry brush
dipped in a little water
to do that.
Or you could just sort
of not be afraid of it,
and let it do its thing.
So it's been boiling or
bubbling for a little while.
So we could take the temperature
of it to see where it's at.
If we got to choose
superpowers in life,
I would like to be able to
tell temperature with my eyes.
I would also like to
hold things in my hand
and know how much they weigh.
If we're talking about what
our dreams are, those are mine.
So this is around 225 degrees.
And it's been cooking
for what, 8 minutes?
JENNA TAYLOR: Not even.
Probably 5.
JAMI CURL: OK, all right.
JENNA TAYLOR: So how
long does it take
to make a batch of lollipops?
Is this an afternoon?
An hour?
JAMI CURL: Oh, an afternoon
from start to finish.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JENNA TAYLOR: A
little bit louder.
AUDIENCE: Do you use
a candy thermometer?
JENNA TAYLOR: Do you
use a candy thermometer?
JAMI CURL: Yeah, yeah.
Well this is like a digital
thermometer that goes up
to 400 degrees, I think.
My preferred brand is the
ThermoPop from ThermoWorks.
But you can use any--
it doesn't have to be like
a big candy thermometer
that like sticks on
the side of the pot.
JENNA TAYLOR: Can it be, though?
JAMI CURL: Well, I actually--
those, you can use.
But I would say, don't
say don't let it just
sit on the side of the
pot, because then you're
just taking the temperature
from one area in the pot.
I like to be able to sort of
swirl the pot a little bit,
and then take the temperature
directly in the middle.
JENNA TAYLOR: OK.
Noted.
JAMI CURL: We
actually teach when
we hire new people at
Quinn which is actually
not that often, thankfully.
We teach like a whole afternoon
of temperature-taking,
because everybody
on the team has
to do it the same way or else
we have all different outcomes.
So they hate me, because I'm
like, OK today's the day.
Get you thermometers.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's important.
JAMI CURL: Yeah, it is.
It is.
Yeah.
So obviously, the side
of your pot it hot.
Don't stick your hand down in
there, because it is boiling.
One thing that about it is that
because it has sugar in it,
it's sticky.
So if it does get
on your skin, it's
not as easy as it is to wipe
boiling water off yourself,
because it will stick to you.
So take care of that.
OK, we're going.
We're going.
OK, what else?
Do we have questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
to the point,
do you take it off
[INAUDIBLE] before or right
when it [INAUDIBLE]?
JAMI CURL: No.
315 for sure.
315 for certain, because you're
going to take it off the pot--
I mean, you're going to
take the pot off the stove.
And then you're going to add
to it the strawberry puree
and a little bit of strawberry
flavoring, and whisk it.
So that will cool it down.
JENNA TAYLOR: Commit to 315.
Let it get all the way there.
JAMI CURL: Yes.
JENNA TAYLOR: What
other questions?
AUDIENCE: Let's
say you do happen
to get sugar on yourself, what
is the best way to get it off?
JAMI CURL: Go to the sink, and
put water on it right away.
JENNA TAYLOR: ASAP.
JAMI CURL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You will cry.
JAMI CURL: What'd you say?
JAMI CURL: Yeah.
He will cry.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is it possible
to burn [INAUDIBLE]??
JAMI CURL: What
was the question?
JENNA TAYLOR: Is it
easy to burn this,
because sugar without the
glucose burns really easily?
JAMI CURL: Yes.
I mean, you would notice
that it's becoming burned,
because it will
change from being
clear to becoming caramelized.
So if you did walk away, and you
came back, and you saw the pot,
and you see that it's
caramelized a little bit,
then you're getting
close to burning it.
So yes, definitely possible.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JAMI CURL: It's time that it's
on the heat and temperature.
This, we're going
to cook this to 315.
When you want something
that's really deep and richly
caramelized, it's only 330, 335.
So there's not a
huge difference.
JENNA TAYLOR: So
the neighborhood
of burning this is
only like 15 degrees.
JAMI CURL: Yes, exactly.
JENNA TAYLOR: Fair.
Anybody else?
Because we got like 90
degrees to go on this thing.
JAMI CURL: We do.
AUDIENCE: We're going
to pass out ice cream.
JAMI CURL: Oh, good.
OK.
JENNA TAYLOR: Ice cream!
Great, thanks, chef.
JAMI CURL: Great.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How quickly should
you eat your [INAUDIBLE] candy?
Do they stay--
JENNA TAYLOR: How quickly
should you eat your candy?
JAMI CURL: With our retail-- we
sell candy across the country.
And we say six months.
The marshmallow recipes
that are in the book,
less they are better
within about eight weeks,
because they are--
fresh marshmallows are like
just the most delicious thing.
So we do recommend
eating them quickly.
But the rest of the candy
is around six months.
It's not that it goes bad.
It's just that it's the most
enjoyable within six months.
JENNA TAYLOR: That's
a good amount of time.
JAMI CURL: I can tell you
this one thing about candy
that I like to tell people.
JENNA TAYLOR: Please.
JAMI CURL: When you notice
that sugar is crystallizing--
so if you have ever had
a roll of Lifesavers,
and you've kept the Lifesavers
in your bag or your pocket
or whatever, and you open
the package a little more,
and you notice that the
one or the two on top
have sort of a
white crust on them,
that is sugar recrystallizing.
It doesn't take a lot.
And it's just that the package
of Lifesavers has been opened.
So the candy can absorb
moisture from the atmosphere
or whatever it is.
Yeah, it's pretty dry here
most of the time, right?
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah, ish.
JAMI CURL: Ish?
Because we made candy in
Portland, and because it
rains all the time.
So we do have dehumidifiers
in our kitchen
just to keep moisture
out of the air.
But you will always
have better luck
with hard candy on
a dry day than you
do on a really wet day.
JENNA TAYLOR: Like a macaron.
JAMI CURL: Yeah, exactly.
JENNA TAYLOR: Can't make
them when it's humid.
JAMI CURL: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Growing up, did
you have a favorite candy?
JENNA TAYLOR: What was your
favorite candy growing up?
JAMI CURL: Oh, yeah.
I loved all candy.
But it depended upon if I
had to buy the candy myself
or if someone else
was buying it.
If someone else was
buying the candy,
I would always choose like
chocolate, delicious candy bars
that were all caramel chocolate,
cookie-type crunchy stuff.
If I was buying the
candy with my own money,
I always bought something
that lasted a long time,
because I was like--
the economics of it, I'm like,
I want either a jawbreaker,
because they lasted forever,
or Fun Dip, because it seemed
to me, you get like, three
sticks of candy and the powder.
And it was just--
seemed like a better deal.
JENNA TAYLOR: I love that
that's your perspective.
JAMI CURL: Oh, yeah.
I like economized
everything as a child.
JENNA TAYLOR: Well you still do.
You were talking about--
[LAUGHS]
JAMI CURL: Yeah, it's true.
Books, like if I had to buy
a book with my own money,
I would buy the
longest book, because I
was, like this is worth--
JENNA TAYLOR: It's a good
investment in your time.
JAMI CURL: Yes.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yes.
JAMI CURL: Yeah, and you
get more for your money
with a longer book.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] now
that we're [INAUDIBLE]??
JENNA TAYLOR: Ice
cream-related questions now
that you're eating ice cream?
JAMI CURL: Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Do you know
what the fat content is?
JAMI CURL: No.
AUDIENCE: Do you know
what the fat content is?
JAMI CURL: Whatever the--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JAMI CURL: Yeah, this
is like a definite,
I would say, cheat on ice cream.
It's just to kind of show
you the possibilities.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's
frozen deliciousness.
JAMI CURL: Yes, so
you could technically
make all of the fruit
purees in the book
and just use those in
any ice cream recipe
that you like to make.
So this is like--
JENNA TAYLOR: So if you
have an ice cream recipe,
you can still just add the fruit
puree and do the same thing.
JAMI CURL: Yes.
Yes.
JENNA TAYLOR: Love it.
Great.
So if you have a favorite,
do that, add the puree.
I like that.
JAMI CURL: Exactly.
JENNA TAYLOR: This
thing is like inching.
JAMI CURL: It really is.
JENNA TAYLOR:
Inching up the chain.
JAMI CURL: It's really trying.
But we can also just, if
we wanted to skip ahead,
we could fake the
end of it probably.
So yes, what's going to
happen once this does reach
the proper temperature is
we're going to add fruit
and in a little bit
of strawberry flavor.
JENNA TAYLOR: Talk to us
about the strawberry flavor.
JAMI CURL: OK, I will.
So we have our flavors
formulated for us
by a natural food producer
that is actually located here
in California.
And so we buy it in very,
very large quantities.
And it's all made
with fruit extracts.
And the same with any of the
candy that has like a color
added to it, we use,
it's like, beet powder,
turmeric-- those types of
things that are all natural.
So you can find online
a natural flavoring.
You just need to
make sure that it's
suitable for high-heat
applications.
JENNA TAYLOR: Thank you.
JAMI CURL: Oh, thank you.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you have a
recommended online retailer
for consumers?
JAMI CURL: To get this stuff?
It depends upon--
you can get all of it
on Amazon if you wanted to.
I mean, it's easy.
Or there is a place in Las
Vegas called Chef Rubber or Chef
"Rub-air."
And they sell every like cake,
candy, mold, tool, ingredients,
like all sorts of stuff.
But I would bet that in
this area of the world,
there's probably some sort of
amazing wholesaler of this type
of stuff that you can shop at.
I'm sure of it.
JENNA TAYLOR: This is delicious.
AUDIENCE: The only
fear with wholesales
is you have to buy
wholesale quantities.
JAMI CURL: It's not usually
like Costco, because usually you
can get a small amount.
I mean, you can get like
one bucket of glucose
or one little bag
of cocoa powder,
because they won't make
you buy a case of it.
They'll break up a case for you.
AUDIENCE: For your caramels,
do you measure the temperature?
Or [INAUDIBLE].
JAMI CURL: No. that's
a great question.
We do it by sight.
JENNA TAYLOR: So do you
measure the temp of caramel
or do it by sight?
JAMI CURL: Yes.
So it's the one
candy in the book
that I don't use
a thermometer for,
because I have found,
in teaching people
how to make caramel
at work, that panic
sets in around the
time the sugar starts
to reach the done point.
And people go crazy.
So I figured out
that if we eliminate
trying to move the pot to keep
the hot spots moving around
and eliminate the idea of trying
to swirl it, hold the blah,
freak out, to teach
people to do it by color.
So in the book,
there's a color chart
that sort of shows
where it starts out
and the journey that it takes to
being slightly cooked, halfway
there, completely finished,
and then the point that you
add the cream and butter.
So it's all done by sight.
And the color that we aim for
sort of like a dirty copper
penny to be finished.
And then you remove the sugar
from the heat, add the fats.
Some of the recipes in
the book use coconut milk.
But it's usually heavy
cream, butter at that point.
And then you whisk it.
AUDIENCE: So you're
ideally trying
to get one specific color,
not like a little range.
JAMI CURL: Right.
One specific color
throughout the pot.
AUDIENCE: Do you typically use
stainless steel or [INAUDIBLE]??
JAMI CURL: For caramel,
we use stainless steel,
but only because
it's less expensive.
But so many candy makers
use big copper pots for it.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask
a quick question?
JAMI CURL: Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The little grainy
bits in [INAUDIBLE],, are those
from strawberries [INAUDIBLE]?
JAMI CURL: I don't know.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Strawberries.
JENNA TAYLOR: Strawberries.
AUDIENCE: I think
it's strawberry.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's the
strawberry, I think.
JAMI CURL: Yes, strawberry.
I believe so.
Maybe the vanilla--
the strawberry, though.
JENNA TAYLOR: Seems
like the strawberry.
JAMI CURL: Strawberry.
Yeah.
Two days from now,
this will be ready.
JENNA TAYLOR: Right?
JAMI CURL: Yeah.
OK, so maybe what we're
going to do is pretend now.
We're going to stick to the--
JENNA TAYLOR: Kitchen magic.
JAMI CURL: This
is like TV magic.
Oh, my gosh.
This thermometer said 315.
So this is all done.
So at this point, what you'll
want to do is, it's at 315.
You turn your heat off.
You remove your
pot from the heat.
And you take your--
well, you get a whisk.
You have your whisk.
You add your flavoring.
You add the puree.
What was that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JAMI CURL: Strawberry.
JENNA TAYLOR: Natural
strawberry flavoring.
JAMI CURL: Yes.
Made for high-heat applications,
if you're shopping for it.
And then you get those
two things in there,
and you whisk this together.
JENNA TAYLOR: It smells amazing.
JAMI CURL: Doesn't it?
JENNA TAYLOR: It reminds me
of a Strawberry Shortcake doll
from when we were little.
JAMI CURL: Yes.
That's a good smell.
JENNA TAYLOR: Dating myself.
But that's exactly
what it smells like.
JAMI CURL: That's a good smell.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's a strong
scent memory from childhood.
JAMI CURL: OK, so then
once you have that done,
if I journey down here, will
everyone be able to see?
Or shall I-- you'll have a
funnel or your measuring cup,
whichever you prefer.
And you just take the
hot, beautiful candy.
And you pour it in there.
And while you have
your funnel full
and you still have some
of the candy in the pot,
you can set it down.
Don't recook it.
That's the only thing
that I can tell you.
So if this hardens a
little while you're
waiting to funnel
your candy out,
do not take what's
in the pot reheat it
to where it's boiling, because
then it will crystallize.
You just got to
leave it like it is.
And then as you get
better at either
using a full funnel or a full
measuring cup so you can do it,
then your yields will
increase and increase
as you get better
at making lollipops.
OK, this is my favorite part.
I have a real stance
when I funnel candy
that I get made fun of
for all the time at work.
But it's very like--
and usually, I'm like,
don't talk to me.
I'm doing like 200 lollipops.
This part's really fun.
You take the funnel,
or you could also
do the measuring cup, and
you essentially-- this
is a $7 object, also.
So it's not like a million--
And the most amazing thing
that we have found out
is that almost every
specialty candy-making item
that is sold America is
made in the state of Ohio.
They are really serious about
their candy and their tools.
So you just lift up on the
plunger and then close it.
And then you have that
really pretty lollipop.
And then you just repeat it.
Do you want to try it?
JENNA TAYLOR: Yes.
JAMI CURL: So here's
what I can tell you.
JENNA TAYLOR: OK,
stance, though.
JAMI CURL: You can
always add more,
but you can't take any away.
So go slow.
AUDIENCE: Oooh.
JAMI CURL: Wow, look at you.
AUDIENCE: Looks like
she's done this before.
JAMI CURL: Yeah, it's like
we practiced, but we didn't.
JENNA TAYLOR: Food team.
JAMI CURL: Oh, thank you.
Is that one good?
JENNA TAYLOR: Just [INAUDIBLE].
JAMI CURL: Something that I like
to do with the lollipops is I
like to take the
Dreams Come True,
which is the fruity,
chewy candy that you have,
and take a little bit of it, and
put it on the end of the stick.
And then put the
stick in the mold.
And the pour the
hard candy over it.
And then you have like a hard
candy with a chewy center.
JENNA TAYLOR: That's awesome.
JAMI CURL: And it's super fun
to mix the flavors that way.
So you could have
strawberry hard candy
with a tangerine center, or
like a super sour hard candy
for the lollipop with
lemon in the middle.
Really delicious
is the chocolate
on the stick with coffee
lollipop around it.
That's very good.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yum.
JAMI CURL: Those recipes are--
AUDIENCE: How do you
do a super sour--
JAMI CURL: How do you do it?
AUDIENCE: --hard candy
that's sugar-based.
JAMI CURL: Oh, let me tell you.
I just figured this out.
She asked how you do a hard
candy that's super sour.
So if you add citric
acid to something,
that obviously makes it sour.
But if you just continue to
add citric acid to candy,
the citric acid starts
eating all of the stuff that
has the sugar sort of hold up.
So we have made
candy that we want
to be super sour with citric
acid, come back to it two days
later, and it's
liquid in the package,
because the citric acid
just eats everything.
So we have figured
out that if you
combine three ingredients
that make things
sour into one sort of slurry,
then make candy with it,
you can make things
hugely, hugely sour,
because none of the three have
enough in the recipe ratio-wise
to break anything down.
AUDIENCE: So does that
mean the sour candy
typically has less sugar in it?
JAMI CURL: It's the same
amount of sugar, actually.
AUDIENCE: So it's
like the citric acid
is masking the sugar content?
JAMI CURL: Yeah, citric acid,
malic acid, and sodium citrate
are the three things
that work for us.
You did it.
JENNA TAYLOR: I did.
JAMI CURL: You should come
to Portland and work for me.
I know I can't pay you as much
as they probably pay you here.
But this is like perfect.
AUDIENCE: The cost of
living is a lot lower.
JAMI CURL: It's a
little bit different.
So the magic--
JENNA TAYLOR: I'll come
and stage with you.
I'll just come and hang out.
JAMI CURL: OK.
All right.
So let's pretend that
one of these is--
I would actually love it.
JENNA TAYLOR: Candy magic.
JAMI CURL: What?
AUDIENCE: Can I try it?
JAMI CURL: Yeah.
Who wants to try this?
Actually, does anyone
else want to try it?
Yes.
OK.
Let's form a little--
let me see here.
Put that in this.
Put the funnel in that.
There we go.
And let's put what was
on the stove in this.
Oh, other thing I can tell you--
as soon as you get
done with this part,
put this pot in the sink
and run water on it.
Otherwise you'll be doing
the dishes all night
long, because it will
really stick to it.
Otherwise, you can fill this
up with water and let it boil.
And then it will boil
with sticky stuff off.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Had that extra just
been sitting on a not hot--
JAMI CURL: That's right.
Yeah.
OK, do you want me to
talk you through it?
AUDIENCE: No.
JAMI CURL: Oh.
No I don't need you
to talk me through it.
JENNA TAYLOR: You got
to get the stance.
That's why.
JAMI CURL: Yeah, if you
get on where you can-- yes.
And the key is always remember.
AUDIENCE: It's really full.
JAMI CURL: Yeah.
The funnel is full.
But always remember,
you can always add more.
But you can't take any away.
So it is kind of nice, too.
AUDIENCE: I just failed
my job interview, guys.
JAMI CURL: You didn't.
You actually did-- look
at your other five.
Your other five are perfect.
OK, Yeah, don't touch it.
Don't touch it.
It is hot.
OK who wants to do-- who
wants to try it also?
Who else wants to do it?
You ready?
OK, yeah, come on.
Let me talk you through it.
All right.
AUDIENCE: So the
stance is down here?
JAMI CURL: The
thing about it is,
you can choose your own
individual stance once you
get into it, you'll
know what your stance
is, personal stance.
OK.
So you'll obviously
want to make sure
that the sticks are
in the circles, right?
And the best thing
I can tell you
is that you just add a
little so that you can
get a feel for how the flow is.
Lift up the plunger slightly.
You don't have to pull
it all the way up.
Just a little, and
then it'll flow out.
Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: So
we've technically
got like five minutes left
in our actual food talk.
What else did we
want to talk about?
Perfect.
JAMI CURL: Look at that.
So good.
Your stance is really good.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's
because of the stance.
JAMI CURL: It's really good.
Also, it doubles
as your workout,
because you're squatting.
JENNA TAYLOR: Got it.
JAMI CURL: Yeah, you're so good.
Yep.
Look at that.
JENNA TAYLOR: Do we want
to have everybody taste
candy side-by-side?
JAMI CURL: Oh, yes.
Do you want to do that?
Would you like to?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JAMI CURL: OK.
Does everybody have the
kit, and the pencil,
a little bag of candy?
Yes?
Everybody does?
No?
JENNA TAYLOR: There are more
down here if anybody doesn't.
Will you hand me
some of the papers?
JAMI CURL: But also, we need to
taste the strawberry lollipops,
right?
Don't we?
I think we do.
AUDIENCE: Do they harden up?
[INAUDIBLE] I mean, you could
pick them up quite quickly.
JAMI CURL: Oh, yeah.
10 to 15 minutes, totally done.
JENNA TAYLOR: And here's
our comparison sheets.
JAMI CURL: And this is the--
these are strawberry
lollipops that we just made,
just magically transformed.
Yes.
JENNA TAYLOR: And how long--
do those have sit overnight?
JAMI CURL: No, just
like 15 minutes.
It's really easy.
JENNA TAYLOR: Right on.
JAMI CURL: OK, and then we'll
wrap one if we have time.
You guys take all those.
Let me get this off my hand.
OK the candy comparison--
this is something
that I like to do
to show people sort of
the real differences
between mass-produced
candy and handmade candy.
OK, so the first
that you have there
is the Dreams Come True, which
is the pink wrapped candy,
and the other fruity candy,
which is the Starburst.
So I only do these
two side-by-side
because so many people
say that they're similar.
But they're not that similar
because the Starburst contains
17 ingredients, and the Dreams
Come True contains five.
JENNA TAYLOR: Enough said.
JAMI CURL: And it uses beet
to get it the pink color.
And we use the natural
flavoring to give it
the natural flavoring.
And the reason that it
doesn't stick to your teeth
and is so smooth and
delicious when you bite it
is because it contains
real dairy butter.
So in a Starburst, it
doesn't have any of that,
so it is a little
like chalky and gross.
Is anyone going to
eat the Starburst?
Does anyone eat
Starbursts regularly?
AUDIENCE: Not regularly.
JENNA TAYLOR: I mean, regularly.
Halloween.
JAMI CURL: That's great.
That is great.
That was great.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] other
colors of Starburst and Dum
Dums that you have to
buy in order to get--
JAMI CURL: Oh, do you
want me to tell you
what we did to get those?
So you can buy Dum Dum
single flavors directly
from the manufacturer.
But the Starburst,
I just went around
to all the bulk grocery stores
and picked the pink ones out so
that I could bring them--
JENNA TAYLOR: And everybody
who bought Starburst was like,
what in the heck?
JAMI CURL: Where are
all the strawberry ones?
JENNA TAYLOR: Because
pink is the best flavor.
JAMI CURL: Yeah.
Yeah, so that's how I did
it, just to be honest.
OK, so the Starburst is
obviously this very tough,
hard brick when you squeeze it.
The Dreams Come True it's very
like smooth and delicious.
The Starburst contains a ton
of gross stuff, like red 40.
In America, we use around 20
million pounds of food dye
every year in our
food system, which
is like the grossest thing.
It has been linked to
hyperactivity in children,
obviously.
Some people believe that
food coloring causes cancer,
or it's a contributing
factor to cancer.
So obviously, if you can
make handy the right way,
you would want to do it.
OK, so the caramel, this is one
of my favorite to talk about.
We make caramel with
sugar, a little bit
of glucose, heavy cream, and
butter, sea salt, some vanilla.
So simple, totally delicious.
Caramel that's made
for mass-production
is made with this stuff
called lipolyzed butter.
And it is taken from
the gullet of a cow
so that they can say that
it's a dairy product.
But it has actually been
so chemically treated
that you need like a pinprick
of it in any ratio of something
you're making to impart
dairy-like flavor.
It's the grossest,
grossest product.
And it's made by the
millions of gallons,
because so many
people put it stuff.
But they say "natural
dairy flavor" on the label.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah,
that's disgusting.
JAMI CURL: And it's
actually this disgust--
so we don't use that.
We make it with real stuff.
AUDIENCE: Do they do that
so it's faster to produce?
JAMI CURL: It doesn't spoil.
It leads to a longer shelf
life is the real thing.
So all of mass-produced candy is
made as cheaply as possible so
that at last for years.
That's like the
main thing with it.
Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: So the
ultimate takeaway
is we can just make our
own delicious candy.
JAMI CURL: Which is
exactly why I'm here, yes.
JENNA TAYLOR: Love it.
JAMI CURL: Yes.
OK.
The lollipop, do you
want to talk about it?
Obviously, fake
coloring in the Dum Dum.
But the cherry lollipop
is so great and beautiful.
Hold it up to the light.
You can see the cherry
skins that are in it.
All the cherries that
these were made with
were grown in Oregon
for us that we bring in.
And we do the same thing
we did with the strawberry,
but with cherries.
JENNA TAYLOR: Love it.
So fun.
Are there any final questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JAMI CURL: Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] now?
[INAUDIBLE] beginning?
JAMI CURL: You
know what you could
do-- this is very tedious.
But maybe you are tedious.
I'm very tedious.
You could take a
little bit of the candy
and pour it in the mold
that doesn't have the stick.
Then set the thing down
inside, like the flower
petal or the herbs or
whatever it is, gold leaf.
Then put the stick
on top of that,
then fill it in with
candy the rest of the way,
sort of like a three-step
layer, three layers.
Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: That's fair.
Anybody else?
Everybody has so much candy.
You're all happy.
JAMI CURL: Yes,
have a lot of candy.
JENNA TAYLOR: Thank you so much.
JAMI CURL: Thank
you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]